-Our next guest
is a talented poet and author
whose debut novel,
"Nightcrawling," is out now.
Please welcome to the show
Leila Mottley, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome to the show, Leila.
-Thanks for having me.
-This is very exciting.
Your book
is not technically out now,
but by the time this show airs,
it will be.
Obviously,
you've put years into it.
How does it feel
knowing the world
will soon be able to read it?
-I still can't fathom that it's
not just living in my head.
So when people come up to me
and they're like,
"I read your book,"
I'm like, "You did?"
[ Laughter ]
So it's surreal, for sure.
-So now, this is the time
where I say something
that I'm very impressed by,
but I think we both know
it's gonna make some people
hate you a little bit.
-Yeah.
-Tell everybody how old you are.
-I turn 20 next week.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
So, Leila, you are --
You are currently
a college student.
-Yes, I'm on break.
-Yeah.
You're studying writing?
-English, yep.
-Yeah. So how do you think
your professors are going
to, um, uh...
[ Laughter ]
...deal with you moving forward?
-Um, I hope that they
do it exactly the same.
I want the same feedback.
But you never know.
I don't know.
-Now, obviously, you've --
I'm guessing you've had great
teachers over the years,
but also your father,
a playwright.
-Mm-hmm.
-Do you feel like you learned
the discipline of writing
from him?
-I learned insomnia.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And staying up late writing,
no sleep.
But I don't know.
I think maybe a little bit.
But...
-So he's not --
'Cause every now and then,
we have a writer on the show,
and they talk about
their schedule
and how they wake up
first thing in the morning,
and they start writing.
That's not you?
-Mnh-mnh.
-Not your dad, either?
-No.
-Okay.
-Late at night.
So that probably made it hard
for him to criticize you
for late nights
and procrastinating
and leaving it
to the last minute.
-No, he would prefer
that I would, like,
watch a show with him
at midnight.
I was 6 years old,
watching "48 Hours."
It was a good time.
[ Laughter ]
-"48 Hours,"
the television show?
-Uh-huh.
-Okay, great.
I was going to say "or the
movie," but both are bad.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Both are not right
for a 6-year-old.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-And I read somewhere
that your dad would pick --
was it a word of the week?
-Yeah.
I mean, every week or so.
He still does it.
But my dad, you know,
he's a writer, and he loves
words, big words in particular.
And so he would try to, like,
fit his new vocabulary word
into every sentence -- like,
literally every sentence.
So I would be, you know, doing
my homework, and he would go,
"You know,
you're sounding quite laconic."
[ Laughter ]
And I would be like, "I just
want help dividing fractions.
I don't know what this is."
And you have to remember,
he is a Black man
from '60s Detroit,
so he would speak, like, normal.
He would just add in these words
no one has ever heard of.
So he would be like, "You know,
that Negro was loquacious."
[ Laughter ]
I learned a lot of words
from him.
-Yeah, that's very good.
Well, obviously,
it's paying off.
So this is inspired
by a real story you read about.
I guess would be --
I mean, you're young now,
so you were incredibly young
when you --
Because this is about, what,
five, six years ago?
How long ago?
-Yeah, so a case broke in 2016
in the Bay Area
where a young girl of color
was sexually exploited
by Bay Area police officers.
And I was a young teenager
at the time.
I'm born and raised in Oakland.
So I paid a lot of attention
to this case,
and I was struck by the way
that the media talked about it
and the lack of focus
on both this young girl
and the harm done to her.
And also, you know,
the thousands of other girls
and women who this happens to,
and we never get to hear it.
-And you wrote it from
the main character Kiara's
first-person perspective.
-Yes.
-Is that a decision that you
made early on in the process?
-First decision.
I like to journal
from my characters' perspectives
and just, like,
immerse myself entirely.
So I spent three months kind of
being inside of them,
and I think that's part of
the special thing about fiction
is you just get to exist
in someone's head.
-Do you journal before you start
writing the novel?
Do you spend all that time --
-And throughout.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah.
-And do you find yourself
discovering new things
about a character
of your own creation
throughout that process?
-Yeah, like, just journaling
about what they ate in the
morning and that kind of thing.
Like, it never ends up on
the page, but it's in my head.
-Well, it obviously pays off.
There's a lot of
wonderful things being written
about this book already.
I don't want to jinx it,
but it's very likely
going to be on
the bestseller list.
And we're just so honored to
have you here talking about it.
Thank you so much
and congratulations.
-Thank you for having me!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys, that's Leila Mottley.
"Nightcrawling" is available now
wherever you buy your books.
But please support local
and independent booksellers.
We'll be back
with more "Late Night."